the Joe Rogan experience so we were
talking about your strength and
conditioning because your knees we kind
of got sidetracked like what kind of
stuff does he have you doing to replace
running and like like off to replace run
like III work in the pool a lot mmm
myself I I run a lot in the pool
and you know I swim - I'm not the best
swimmer in the world but you know I get
in and I get after and I get tired you
know those things at GSP uses where he
has like these yeah I see what's on his
hands and all his feet no you like I
play with those yeah what are those
things
um they kind of they create the
resistance in the water you know so it
kind of gives you the resistance pulling
pushing and then you know throwing
punches with them it just gives you that
extra work that you need George loves
that show he loves it it's like his main
training or in strengthening if I could
if I could give you a magic wand to come
on you can pick Bing who you pointing
that magic wand yes be all that GSP all
day just for the legend status yeah
because um George did he went out the
way you're supposed to know and he could
still do it he proved it to if they came
back and not just do it go up a weight
class and get it done he can still do
his training he's one of those guys it's
not just gonna stop training he's been
trained he's still training and I know
he can compete still Feroz says he's
still the best [ __ ] guy he's ever
seen
he's like the guys still a [ __ ] man
right now in the gym training hard like
nobody could touch him yeah and I like
to test that you know with and I think
respect to George this is no disrespect
by any means but there's a reason guys
like myself and and kabhi want to fight
him mm-hmm is because we we want to test
ourselves this is not a matter of
disrespect and I want to beat this guy's
ass no it's George was the best he did
everything the right way and and got to
the top and walked away and he can still
do it so we want to test herself against
a guy like that because we we pride
ourselves on being the best we've worked
tirelessly to get to this point to where
it's not as if hype it's not for the
money
like all that is good yeah
you know that that's great but we want
to test ourselves against the best to
ever do it and that's what George
symbolizes and of course myself I'm he's
in my weight I'm you know now I'm the
king he was the king like it's
interesting that you would prefer that
over Conor because I think the Conor
fight would be the biggest payday right
absolutely
I think ah you don't think so I don't
know red Patty's I mean the last
pay-per-view they're saying tract just
below Connor and khabib it's a [ __ ]
they think it's more than 2 million
pay-per-view buys Wow huge huge has come
back yet that [ __ ] has charisma
absolutely and you can't take anything
away from Conor man Conor has put
himself in that in that part in that
status to be that guy and even sometimes
I have to think man like that because
some guys get envious of that like how
did he do that like some guys are you
special like that and Conor is that guy
he's special like that yeah you know so
he people just gravitate towards him and
he you know special guy but can you
imagine me fighting Conor like that
wouldn't even be fair it would not be
fair like I give everyone has a punches
chance but he would not be fair like you
saw what come even did to him
at 55 and I imagine me doing that to him
at 7 and I'm not just gonna take him
down
I'm I'm gonna march forward I'm gonna
hit this guy I'm gonna beat on him I'm
gonna take him down I'm going to I would
do some some bad things to Conor and and
not just because I it's not that I don't
like the guy I mean Conor's Conor you
just think that he's a natural 55 yeah
and he fought at 45 and you shot both
your [ __ ] legs off to make 45 that's
when they say impossible and that's
absolutely am literally impossible
you'd have to get a tapeworm yeah it
would be it would be bad like you ever
seen I do you ever seen me that way get
down to wait yeah I look real African no
no you a very fancy very thin you can
tell you're
and a lot of water
[Applause]